versteh ja verstehe nicht was du meinst ja die
Klöse sind nicht warm aber deine Stirn wo ist
denn der Papa aha der feberthermometer liegt wie
immer unten links im Schrank ich muss jetzt hier
weitermachen warum werden eigentlich immer
nur die Mütter angerufen na weil die Väter
Arbeiten ihr Kind ist krank oh aber die
Selbstverwirklichung geht eben vor ne
jetzt pass mal auf Schampus Max wenn
die aus spricht hat die Perle Pause
verstanden nein den Spruch merkst Du Dir nicht so
hinsetzen sie ein Verfassungsfeind sind ist ja
jetzt klar geworden die Demokratie hat gerade
noch einen Arzttermin bis sie da ist prüfen
wir noch schnell die zweite Voraussetzung für
ein erfolgreiches AFD Verbot die sehr gerne
wollen sie es persönlich prüfen nicht in 1000
Jahren sie müssen ja nicht ich habe acht Kinder
bekommen sie haben acht Kinder bekommen nicht
persönlich Potentialität bedeutet hat die AFD
eine realistische Chance an die Macht zu kommen
das mpdverbot ist ja nur daran gescheitert weil
man sie für zu unbedeutend gehalten hat um eine
iche Gefahr dazustellen wissen Sie was meiner
Potenzialität am meisten helfen würde wenn
jemand mit mir [Musik] koaliert genau das wissen
Sie was wir jetzt machen oh ich kann es mir sehr
gut vorstellen wir rufen Friedrich märz in den
Zeugenstand das habe ich mir anders [Applaus]
vorgestellt
Tag mein lieber Fritze Herr März sie duzen sich
also mit der AFD wand sich daine Zusammenarbeit an
das kam ausschließlich von ihm ja hör sofort auf
damit gerne wie du willst Fritze ich bin nicht ihr
Fritze was Zier denn noch so in Thüringen hast
es dir doch auch besorgen lassen die Mehrheit
meine ich Frau richichter in Thüringen haben sie
da gerade gejendert nein ich habe gesagt Frau
Richter in Thüringen schon wieder na was soll ich
sagen Frau Richter auf Thüringen gut kurz hatte
ich gedacht ich habe dich verloren niemals also
was ich meine ist es gibt keine Zusammenarbeit
zwischen der AFD und der nein heißt nein ja da
darf ich mal den deutschen schlagerpoeten Gigi
Anderson zitieren der gesagt hat nein heißt
ja wenn man lächelt so wie du da möchte ich
mit Matthias Reim Antworten verdammt ich lieb dich
ich lieb dich nicht die grunderwerbssteuersenkung
in Thüringen war unsere Idee sie haben dem Antrag
nur zugestimmt ein Antrag von uns war von 2018 da
haben sie damals abgelehnt auf staatspolitische
Verantwortung kommen sie und einmal jetzt Copy
und Paste und Einspruch euer Ehren wir haben
ja extra noch einen familienbonus hinzugefügt
damit das nicht so auffällt warum muss eigentlich
immer ich mich rechtfertigen ja ich finde auch da
in Thüringen da ging es um eine Steuersenkung das
ja nicht gleich rechsextrem aber in Gütersloh da
musste eine NS Gedenkstätte geschlossen werden
weil CDU Freie Wähler und AFD die Ausbaukosten
nicht tragen wollten die CDU ist ja nicht per se
dagegen die wollen nur wenig Geld dafür ausgeben
das ist ja auch sparsam zu sein nicht gleich
rechtsextrem die CDU hat auch gesagt sie haben
das nur gemacht damit die Bürger nicht AFD
wählen ja guck mal dann ist das Schließen
von NS Gedenkstätten jetzt eigentlich der Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus darauf trinken wir die
AFD wirkt hier Fritze dass du auch mal wieder was
Hochprozentiges siehst da sage ich nicht nein ich
sage nein von der AFD nehme ich nichts an fui
ist aber schade das hat euer sechsischer CDU
Gemeinderat bei uns daagelassen als ein Bundestag
zu Besuch war auf Einladung der AFD Fraktion ach
so dann kommt ja eigentlich auch von uns na
in dem Fall warum ist das ein kleiner Feigling
[Musik] Rust sie sehen sie sehen Frau Richterin
wir haben nicht zusammen getrunken Fritze was
zierst du dich denn so komm sind zwei Schnitzel
vom selben Schwein weißt du noch kleinen Paschas
deutsche Zahnarzttermine nur für deutsche zu
der zahnthematik die ganze Republik muss nicht
in Schnappatmung verfallen nur weil ich
auf eine echte Überforderung hingewiesen
habe es war ja eine Lüge wieso ich habe ja auf
meine Überforderung hingewiesen dann ist es in
Ordnung ja ich kann jetzt auch nicht verstehen sie
verstehen Sie das doch verstehen Sie das doch ich
kann jetzt auch nicht alles weglassen was mich zu
einem kernigen Typen macht nur weil er das vorher
schon gesagt hat wussten sie dass Fritze und ich
jeweils in der jungenunion waren und in der CDU
wir wollen exakt dasselbe na davon träumen sie
wir haben ab und an ähnliche Ziele Fritze das
tut mir jetzt weh ab und an ähnliche Ziele komm
laut wahomat haben wir ein türingen und Bayern
überereinstimmung von 74% bei Themen wie Klima
Energie Finanzen h wir liegen bundesweit so nah
beieinander wir haben sogar einen gemeinsamen
Feind Schag ein da irren sie sich ich habe nur
gesagt dass die Grünen unser Hauptgegner sind ja
ja der habbeck sollte eigentlich hier stehen ne
komm Fritze gibt zu die Wärmepumpe hat dich
auch [__] ich habe aber auch gesagt dass
sie der Feind der Demokratie sind nicht mehr
lange dauert nicht mehr lange dann wirst Du
uns anbetteln um zusammenarbeiten wenn wir
in thürgen nächstes Jahr 33,3% kriegen und
irgendwie mag ich die Zahl dann haben wir eine
Sperrminorität ja da können wir die Besetzung
von Richtern blockieren dann blockieren wir
Gerichtsprozesse dann laufen mörderfi rum weil
ihr nicht mit uns zusamm gearbeitet hat und wenn
dann die Forderung immer lauter werden und ihr
wollt dann Zusammenarbeit mit uns dann wird es
immer teurer komm Fritze trink doch gleich mit
uns Brust Brust Kamerad prostpost kamerat wir
wollen einen heben von der Mitte zum Fritze zum
Sack zack zack sehen Sie Frau Richterin ich
sehe wie das alles hier auf sie wirken muss
aber sie müssen verstehen ich befinde mich in
einer Zwick Mühlen ich kann nicht mit ihm und
auch nicht ohne ihn wir sind wie Tristan und
Isolde ist gut alles gut du bist Isolde nein
sie sind Isolde echte Männer sind keine Isolde
Tristan stirbt zuerst dann bin ich die solde ich
fasse ihre Auseinandersetzung jetzt mal auf ihrem
Niveau zusammen tausend Mal berührt tausend Mal
ist nichts passiert ja das sag ich doch die ganze
Zeit Nacht und es hat Zoom gemacht gefällt mir ich
glaube ich brauche jetzt erstmal ein kühles
Bier fantastische Idee Fritze notieren Sie
bitte die Idee mit dem Bier war meine er hat nur
zugestimmt ich komm sch [Applaus] mit wiren nur
soll sich das kann da sehr gut auf mich selber
aufpassen so her haben sie abonniert Glocke
gedrückt sich eines von den beiden Videos
hier angeschaut reicht mir vollkommen dass
ich in den meisten mitspielen muss glauben
Sie dass es die richtige Art ist für uns
Werbung zu machen wer ich dafür bezahlt
nee was zum Henker ma ich dann hier er
ist sonst nicht so sie können sich ja in
der Zwischenzeit was ohne ihn anschauen